Pat Garrett once admitted that the thing he feared most was having his life
defined by just one moment, the killing of William age,
Bon be known as Billy the kit.
He said he dreaded meeting new people because they always said something along
the lines of, Hey, your pat Garrett, the guy that shot Billy the kit,
unfortunately for the law man, his worst fear came to pass.
Not only in his lifetime, but also in modern times.
His legacy is inexorably tied to the killing of Bonnie,
which I guess is just what happens when you gun down.
One of the biggest icons of the wild west,
there was another problem as the Outlaw's reputation grew.
And he was turned into a legend of the old west sympathy for him,
increased Garrett slowly,
but surely was becoming the villain of this tale. Sure. Billy,
the kid was a ruthless murderer who killed many people in cold blood,
but people could not help,
but feel like Garrett acted somewhat cowardly by gunning him down in the dark.
This was not how the heroes of the wild west actors in their imaginations.
If the two had met an ado,
then the story would've probably have been remembered vastly differently that
have been boast cool points for Gar.
If he would've snapped a one line over shooting and then lit agar afterwards,
as it stands though,
pat Garrett sits in a gray area of Western law where some people admire
him as a tough lawman in a lawless land and others brand him as a coward.
But as we are about to see his life continued with other thrills and adventures
after the death of Bonnie culminating with Garrett's own mysterious murder
that still puzzles people to this very day.
He was born Patrick Floyd, Jarvis Garrett on June the fifth,
1850 in chambers county, Alabama to John Lumpkin,
Garrett and Elizabeth Jarvis at a young age,
he relocated with his family to Louisiana and his father bought a cotton
plantation in Clayborn parish. At first,
things went pretty well for the Gara family is the plantation flourished,
but things took a drastic turn for the worst. When the civil war broke out,
it completely ruins the family's finances.
And then both parents died less than a year apart in 1867 and 1868,
respectively leaving behind a plantation full of debt.
Pat younger siblings were taken in by various relatives. However,
when Garant 18 years old, he saw no reason to stick around anymore.
And in 1869, he rode alone into the sunset.
Very few details unknown about the next years of Garrett's life.
He settled in Texas for a while near the Dallas area where he worked as a farm.
He, a few years later,
he became a Buffalo hunter on the staked planes and started a bus selling their
hides. However, this was not a sustainable career.
People like Gareth almost hunted the American Buffalo,
which is actually a bison for the technical into extinction.
Tens of millions of specimens were killed during the 19th century. At one point,
reducing their numbers do only a few hundred in the entire country.
Once the supply started running out,
Garrett left Texas and drifted towards Fort Sumner in New Mexico.
Before we get there. However,
there is still another important events from pat Garrett's life to discuss.
And that's the first time he killed a man.
It happens around 1870 and the victim was a friend of Garretts and a fellow
Buffalo hunter named Joe Brisco.
The two of them got into an argument over who knows what?
And it escalated to the point of violence and enraged Brisco charged a Garrett
with an ax, prompting the latter to grab a pistol and shoot his attacker.
A point blank range.
Allegedly as he lay there dying Brisco was the one who asked forgiveness of his
shooter. Reducing Garrett tears backed with Guild.
The killer tried to turn himself in for Griffin,
but the authorities there had no interest in prosecuting him.
So Gareth just got on with his life. When he arrived in New Mexico,
Garrett found work as a cowboy. Again, it's Pedro Pete Maxwell's ranch.
This is the same house where he would kill Billy the kid. If you, years later,
during this time he also married a woman named Juanita gueras,
who would die less than a year into their marriage during childbirth,
Gar would not stay single for long though. And in 1880,
he remarried to apple and AERA. The 17 year old,
younger sister of his first wife,
they would go on to have eight children together.
That same year Garrett was elected sheriff of Lincoln county,
New Mexico territory, and immediately set aside on Billy,
the kids and the other gunslingers he rode with by this point, Billy,
the kid had already earned his fame.
Thanks to his involvement in the Lincoln county war,
which you can learn about in depth in our biographics video on Billy the kit,
basically the Lincoln county war was a violent feud that started in 1878,
between two factions that both wanted a monopoly over the dry goods business.
On one side,
there was the older established group led by James Dolan and Lawrence Murphy who
already operated the largest general good store in Lincoln county known simply
the house on the other was this new partnership between businessmen,
John TSOL and Alexander MCWE who opened a R store to
add fuel to the fire.
Both groups also had some serious backup in the form of gangs,
willing to protect their side's interests with violent diligence.
Dolan's faction had the Jesse Evans gang best are known as the boys and also
had the county sheriff William J. Brady in his pocket.
The newcomers had the regulators, a group of leastly,
affiliated Cowboys and ranch hands who had a history with each other.
This included Billy, the kid and other Des Desperados such as Dick brewer,
doc schlock, co cousins, Tomo, Folley art, and Charlie Bower.
The in king county war, it kicked off properly on February the 18, 18 78.
When the boys killed John Tusall.
This is when the regulators formed into a more cohesive gang.
And at the start, at least even had the law on their side.
As they received warrants from justice of the peace, John Wilson,
to bring Tom stalls killers to justice.
The feud was marked by multiple shootouts and revenge killings. Billy the kid,
and a few other regulators killed sheriff Brady.
Although dozens of other people died.
This was the murder that would send Bonnie on the run with pat Garrett on
his tail door culminated with a five shootout known as the battle of
Lincoln, where Alexander MCWE was also killed with both businessmen dead.
The regulators had nobody to work for any mobs. So they just scattered.
By the time Garrett started chasing Billy the kids that bladder was already a
notorious gunman own throughout the country.
He and a few other regulators like Bower,
and Feria decided to stick together after the Lincoln county war and engage in
additional acts of mayhem, violence, and murder.
They also joined up with dirty Dave Ru Debar and other infamous outlaw of the
old west.
Billy the kids gang first crossed guns with Garretts in late 1880 onto some of
the 19th, the gang road into for Sumner, New Mexico,
where Garrett was already waiting for them assisted by another lawman named LA
chambers.
He confronted Tom Oliar and another former regulator named Tom pickers.
One of oard went for his gun. Garrett shot him in the chest.
He died less than an hour later aged 22, but the other Outlaws,
they managed to make a run for just a few days later on December the 23rd,
he tracked the whole gang to an abandoned farmhouse near stinking Springs,
New Mexico. And this time he had a large posse with him.
It seemed like Garrett had the situation completely in control,
but the gang still preferred a shootout over surrender. Former regulator,
Charlie Bower was killed during this encounter.
The rest eventually came to their and gave up after a two day siege.
If this would've been the end of the road for Billy,
the kid Garrett might have been unanimously remembered as a hero.
He was brave and diligence in his pursuit of the Outlaws only killed when
absolutely necessary and managed to bring the other criminals to justice.
Unsurprisingly,
Bonnie was convicted for the murder of sheriff Brady and sentenced to hang until
he was dead, dead, dead, which is what the judge told him. According to legend.
However, on April the 28th, while awaiting execution,
Bonnie managed to outmaneuver his guards when only one deputy named James Bell
was watching him.
They asked to be taken out to the outhouse where he attacked his century,
the kid shot and killed bell with his own gun. Afterwards,
he armed himself with a shotgun,
waited for Bob Allinger the other guard to return. And then he killed him too.
Bonnie then jumped onto a horse and rode out of town.
Garrett wasn't in town when Billy the kid escaped,
but he soon returned and started chasing him again. A few months later,
the lawman, uh, is that his fugitive had returned to Fort Sumner.
He went to visit Pete Maxwell's ranch because he suspected that Bonnie might be
hiding that the exact sequence of events is up for some debate.
But according to the most common version on the night of July, the 14th,
Garrett was sitting in the dark in Maxwell's bedroom,
Bonnie beded the room and asked who was there and upon recognizing his voice,
the sheriff shot him twice without saying anything. Billy,
the kid was dead before he, Ethan hit the ground
Word of laws. Demise traveled fast. As the story of Billy,
the kid was plastered on every newspaper in the country.
Bonnie was slowly being turned into a folk hero rather than a lifelong criminal
who was on the run after mercilessly killing two deputies.
Moreover Garrett was the one that the media chose to portray as the cold blooded
assassin. He couldn't stand this. So when 1880,
he wrote his own accounts with the help of a ghost writer to set the record
straight. It was titled the authentic life of Billy, the kids.
And it became for a while,
the definitive version of events that went down at Peter Maxwell's ranch,
however,
it was later found to contain many inaccuracies and historians dismissed it as
an embellished narrative with the occasional truth thrown in for while the
newspapers went way overboard with their sympathetic portrayal of Billy the
kids, because it made a better story.
Garrett's accounts veered too much in the opposite direction as its main goal
was to clear his own name rather than give a factual description of the events.
Most notably Garrett's version changes the part where he gunned down Bonnie in
the dark without giving him a chance to surrender in a hand shot.
First type scenario.
The sheriff alleged that the kid raised his cocked pistol foot away from Gareth
us leaving him with no choice, but to pull the trigger.
Garrett did not seek re-election as sheriff and instead had a brief stint with,
for Texas Rangers. After that was over,
he left law enforcement for about a decade time during which he tried to enter
the irrigation industry, Gar lived on a larger ranch near Roswell, New Mexico.
He soon realized that in many arid,
undeveloped regions of the Southwest irrigation was a necessity for any kind of
successful agriculture in his area.
That irrigation would've come courtesy of the pay river,
which Garrett thought could be damned and used to construct a large scale canal.
One anecdote that definitely isn't true.
Even stated that he originally got the idea from Billy,
the kid who told him that he could grow crops and make lots of money.
Instead of chasing guys like him during the mid 1880s,
Gar met businessman Charles Eddie,
who was in the process of buying as much possible with his own plans to invest
in an irrigation system.
Eventually the two decided to combine their ventures to one large reclamation
project.
They were also joined by a third entrepreneur called Charles Green and in 1888,
the Payco irrigation and investment company was born as the project grew and
more businessmen joined the venture.
Garrett was slowly re to an increasingly smaller role,
although this could have been done because others were simply more experienced
than him.
One Garrett biographer asserts that it was a deliberate effort to push him outta
the company.
The lawman wasn't quite ready to leave the business completely.
So instead he purchased a one third interest in the Texas irrigation ditch
company and forms another business called the Holoman and Garrett ditch company
with entrepreneur William Homan,
both companies failed and eventually Garrett abandoned this far,
completely and relocated to Texas.
After almost a decade and a half of relative obscurity.
Pat Garrett was once again in the headlines in 1896,
due to his involvement in the disappearance case of Colonel Albert Jennings
fountain and his 80 year old son,
Henry fountain was an attorney with the Texas Senate who made a lot of dangerous
enemies.
When he went after powerful men involved in cattle or rusting in the New Mexico
territory in late January, 1896,
he and his son were traveling by wagon back to their home in New Mexico.
They disappeared and were presumed murdered on February.
The first near white Sams suspicion fell on two wealthy ranches and rivals
of fountain Oliver Lee and Albert fall.
The scandal was front page news across the country, governor William thorns,
and did the matter resolved.
So he coasted pat Garrett out of retirement by making him sheriff of the county
Garrett located the spot where the presumed murders took place.
The ground was soaked in blood, and there was a smaller pool of blood,
a few feet away searching the area,
the sheriff and his posse also found empty cartridge, casings,
fountains tie some of his papers and his buckboard and stained with blood.
It was pretty clear. Something very violent took place there,
but investigators were never able to find the bodies to make matters.
More difficult tracks that led away from the area had been accidentally erased
by a passing herd of cattle, which by complete coincidence,
belongs to Oliver Lee.
Gareth thought Lee was the cot alongside with two of the ranchers employee,
Jim Gillian and William MCNE.
The sheriff obtained arrest warrants for all three. He placed MCNE in custody,
but the other two made a run for it.
Garrett pursued the murder suspects and on July the 12th, 18 90,
80 caught up to them to the wildy. Well ranch near the VI mountains,
a shoot house sued, but it did not go in Garrett's favor.
One of his deputies was hit twice as a situation was deteriorating.
The sheriff was forced to back down and call the truth so that he could get
medical attention to his deputy. Coney died shortly thereafter.
Lee and Gillin stayed on the run for another eight months before finally
surrendering at trial, they were represented by Albert fall, the,
by the landowner who hated fountain and according to some might have even
orchestrated the whole assassination plot.
Now fall was not just a wealthy rancher.
He was also a good lawyer and an influential politician. In fact,
he would like to serve as secretary of the interior and to president Warren
haunting. Thanks to his involvement in pot.
Dom scandal full has the dubious distinction of being the first us cabinet
member in history to be convicted and served prison time for a felony during the
trial Garrett's reputation worked against him.
Lee argued that the shootout it wildly well was in self defense because pat
Garrett had no intention of taking him and Gillian alive.
If they surrendered that sheriff would've gunned them down in cold blood,
this story alongside falls, AEP defense,
and the lack of bodies ensured that the suspects walked away free,
not even being charged in deputy Kearney's death. Not only that,
but Oliver Lee went on to have a successful political career and there is a
state park named after him.
No one else was ever charged in the murder and disappearance of Albert and Henry
Fallon. And it remains one of new Mexico's biggest unsolved mysteries.
The last highlight of Garrett's law enforcement career happens in 1899 when he
was pursuing a fugitive wanted for murder, who was called Norman Newman.
The chase ended in a gun fight where the sheriff shot the criminal and thus
Norman Newman became to bar knowledge.
The last man that was killed by pat Garrett,
Garrett had a stroke of luck in 1901 when Teddy Roosevelt became president of
the United States and a deep fondness for famed frontier lawman,
who he said co to those Vikings like Hastings and Ralo who finally
served the course of civilization.
He gave jobs to several of them over the course of his two terms as president,
including Seth Bullock of Deadwood fame and bat Masterson,
consequently in 1901,
pat Gar became collector of customs in El Paso Gareth's appointment was not well
received.
Despite numerous Plains Roosevelt seemed to determine to stick by his man
though.
Allegedly the last straw came when Garris attended a presidential party and
brought along a guest named Tom powers.
He introduced him to the president as a successful cattleman,
and the two took several photos together,
bony for Roosevelt to find out later that powers was actually the owner of a
notorious saloon in El Paso.
After that resident refused to renew Garrett's appointment in 1905.
Most of the popular icons of the wild west met violent ends.
And pat Garrett was no exception on February the 29th,
19 0 80 was shot on the way to last crus,
New Mexico and died age 50 Evan ostensibly,
his killer was a man named Jesse Wayne Brazel who acted in self defense.
He turned himself in and confessed. That is trial.
He was defended by none other than Albert full. And he was acquitted.
It would appear to be case closed except that none of Garrett's relatives and
indeed,
most historians believe that Brazel was actually the one who pulled the trigger.
There are a lot of co theories floating around regarding Garrett's murder.
Here are the facts as best we know them. And you can form your own opinion.
Garrett was in a dispute with Brazel over some lands that the former had leased
to the latter for five years,
Garrett wanted to break the lease when he discovered the Brazel was going to use
his property for goat grazing also involved was a man named prince road,
a friend of bras and, and of Gar,
who would run-ins with him while still a sheriff. We should also mention WW Cox,
a wealthy round show from the area who also hated Garrett and possibly wanted
his land.
Eventually the two sides reached an agreement where Brasel would terminate his
lease. If he had a buyer for his goat hurt.
This is where another man enters the picture called Carl Adamson.
The exact details of the agreements are a bit murky,
but they're really beside the point.
What matters is that on the morning of February, the 29th,
pat Garrett Adamson Razel were traveling together to last cruises.
This is when Razel shot Garrett twice and then turned him Finn to the county
Sheriff's office. Exclaiming lock me up.
I've just killed pat Garrett Adamson acted as a witness and corroborated bras
story that an argument caused Garrett who reach for his shotgun,
but Razel drew quicker. And who knows, maybe this is indeed what happens.
There were a few things suspicious about Garrett's death,
such as the fact that allegedly the former of share was shot in the back of the
head. And this was never brought up at the trial. And speaking of the trial,
how come of all people Albert fall was the one who defended Brazel.
He had close ties to the judge and the prosecutor in the case,
and also Rancho WW car who some sea,
as the mastermind of the whole plot Garson believed Adamson was the killer and
some agreed others ink.
It was print road who caught up to the trio and took his revenge.
And there's another major suspect we haven't even mentioned yet.
An outlaw named Jim Miller,
better known as killing Jim or killer Miller who sometimes acted as a gun for
hire and just happened to be in the area.
One popular theory says that Miller was paid by Cox to do the deed.
We probably won't agree on what happened since none of us can note for certain
what we can agree on is that getting shot in the back of the heads and being
dumped on the side of the road was a disgraceful undeserving end for a man
once called by Billy the kit historian,
Walter Noble burns as the last great sheriff of the old frontier.
So I really hope you found that video interest. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this four times per week.
So hit that subscribe button to find out about all of those. Also,
why not check out our sister channel called geographics?
It's all about geography, obviously from the title and as always our CNX time,